even when there's an entire Health Care
System Under Pressure individual stories
can still shock
as well as being ill it was complete and
utter misery that's your chemotherapy
tablet Edward Denmark has blood cancer
it makes him extremely vulnerable to
colds and flu so he tries to stay
isolated but last week he got an
infection and needed emergency treatment
he says his local Hospital's acute Ward
was chaos
it was very packed as it always is
and again I can't sit on the chairs with
the people so you either put us in the
store cupboard
there's like a stalker but there we
either sit in there but on this occasion
um the store cupboard was locked or
something he ended up in a corridor not
being seen for hours Delirious with
fever and frightened about catching
another infection I shouldn't say this I
thought is this fight worth it what am I
fighting for over here if I feel unwell
now
I think what have I got to go through
before and get the antibiotics in me
the NHS trust that treated Edward told
us that like across the Health Service
it's seeing unprecedented demand for
emergency care that staff are doing all
they can to see the sickest Patients
First
everybody's finding it very very
difficult and it's not at all what
people go into health care for it's all
for waiting if you're ill if you're
worried about it it's absolutely
Dreadful even if that condition isn't
getting worse which sometimes it is and
it's just it's just an unacceptable
service
and that's out of a person's mouth who
has got more experience than anyone
sitting in government now if the
government don't listen to her they're
not going to listen to anyone but the
government says it is listening and
responding there's been particular
pressures over Christmas because we've
had a surge in flu cases covet cases and
also a lot of concern around strappe
we're putting more funding in we've got
more clinicians we've got more staff
working in the NHS of course there's a
range of factors that we need to do but
so far these reassurances aren't enough
to prevent more planned strike action or
make current patients feel safe
Catherine difficulty Sky News